This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Like millions of people around the world, Stanford economist Nicholas Bloom has been working from home since March 2020. Instead of a university classroom, he now uses a spare bedroom. Sometimes, one of his four kids pops in while he does meetings over Zoom. He'll never forget this one time when he was in a very important call with some business executives trying to help them with a research project. About 20 minutes into the call, this happened. It was two of my kids starting their daily practice on the bagpokes.
这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。和全球数以百万计的人一样，斯坦福大学经济学家尼古拉斯·布鲁姆自2020年3月以来一直居家办公。他现在不再使用大学教室，而是用一间空余的卧室办公。有时，他四个孩子中的一个会在他开Zoom会议时闯进来。他永远不会忘记有一次，他正在与一些企业高管进行非常重要的通话，试图帮助他们完成一个研究项目。通话进行了大约20分钟时，发生了这样一幕。那是我的两个孩子开始他们每天的“袋子戳戳”练习。
practice on the bagpokes. I was thinking, oh no, no, now is not the time. Had to like say quickly to Evan and meet him, sorry, there's something going on in the background, mute myself and like run into the toilet. Ah, to take the rest of the meeting in there, because it was the only place that was quiet enough. And our house isn't that big, and you know, the soundproofing is just dreadful.
“袋子戳戳”练习。我当时心想，噢不，不，现在可不是时候。我不得不赶紧对埃文说让他静音，抱歉，背景里有点动静，然后把自己静音，像跑进厕所一样。啊，在里面完成剩下的会议，因为那是唯一足够安静的地方。我们的房子没那么大，而且你知道，隔音效果简直太糟糕了。
The toilet's about the only sound bunkered room, so I'm sure I'll be back in there again taking calls. Probably many calls, because Nick is an expert on the economic, cultural and social implications of working from home. Now, in an almost surreal twist, he's living his research day in and day out, just like many of us. So, he's working from home, working.
厕所几乎是唯一隔音的房间，所以我肯定还会再进去接电话。可能会有很多电话，因为尼克是居家办公在经济、文化和社会影响方面的专家。现在，在一个近乎超现实的转折中，他像我们许多人一样，日复一日地过着他的研究生活。所以，他在居家办公，在工作。
So many people said, you know, we thought we'd be great at this, we thought we could deal with it, I thought I was mentally strong, I didn't like many of my employees, but I realized after, you know, three or four months, maybe I didn't miss them. This week on Hidden Brain, the final installment in our work 2.0 series, we revisit a favorite show about the psychological challenges and the possibilities of working from home in the COVID era and beyond.
很多人说，你知道，我们以为自己会很擅长这个，我们以为自己能应付得来，我以为我在心理上很强大，我不喜欢我的许多员工，但我意识到在三四个月后，也许我并不想念他们。本周在《Hidden Brain》中，我们“工作2.0”系列的最后一期，我们将重温一期关于新冠时代及以后居家办公的心理挑战和可能性的热门节目。
Before economist Nick Bloom became a professor at Stanford, he walked in London for a consulting company. He often worked from home and back then his co-workers made a lot of assumptions about what he did all day. I know there was endless joking about working from home, shurking from home, working remotely, remotely working. So, you know, they would wind me up and claim I was watching as old fashion black on my, you know, TV movies that were on during the day, I was watching the cricket being British, but I honestly, I promise you, I was working, but it didn't feel like other people thought that was true. You probably had the cricket in the background though, didn't you? Yeah, I mean, I have to say, I'm not a big fan of cricket unless it comes to revising for my exams. To the point the cricket became fascinating, because you know, it was like anything's fascinating compared to revising
在经济学家尼克·布鲁姆成为斯坦福大学教授之前，他在伦敦一家咨询公司工作。他经常居家办公，那时他的同事对他整天在做什么做了很多假设。我知道关于居家办公、在家偷懒、远程工作、远程办公的笑话层出不穷。所以，你知道，他们会捉弄我，声称我白天在看老式黑白电视电影，或者在看板球比赛，因为我是英国人，但我诚实地向你保证，我当时在工作，但感觉其他人并不相信这是真的。你当时背景里可能放着板球比赛吧？是的，我的意思是，我必须说，我不是板球的忠实粉丝，除非是为了复习考试。以至于板球变得引人入胜，因为你知道，相比于复习，任何事情都显得很有趣。
The assumptions that people have long held about working from home you can see them reflected in our searches online Some time ago Nick looked at what you see when you search for the phrase working from home on the web You know, I gave a few talks. I have to say before COVID, I did a bit of, you know, research and talks and stuff over the years for quite a while. And one thing I used to explain to people is one good way to tell how negatively viewed working
人们长期以来对居家办公的假设，你可以从我们的在线搜索中看到反映。前段时间，尼克查看了你在网上搜索“居家办公”这个短语时会看到什么。你知道，我做过几次演讲。我必须说在新冠疫情之前，多年来我确实做过一些研究和演讲之类的。我过去常向人们解释的一件事是，判断居家办公被看待得有多负面，一个好方法就是去谷歌或必应搜索，在“居家办公”这个词下进行图片搜索。如果你这样做，我截了图，并在2017年的TEDx演讲中展示了它，你知道，我展示了前15个搜索结果，也就是前两排图片，它们基本上是裸体的人、卡通画、膝盖上抱着婴儿的人。说实话，在15个结果中，只有两个是正面图片，有13个简直太糟糕了。你知道，最糟糕的是那个在按摩浴缸里喝香槟的家伙，这被看待得太负面了。
from home was was just to go into Google or Bing and just search to an image search under the words, working from home. And if you do that, I screen shoted it for it and showed it in the TEDx talk in 2017 and you know I showed the top 15 hits that took you know the top two rows of images and they were basically naked people, cartoons, people juggling babies on their lap. They're honestly out of the 15, there are only two that were positive images, there were 13 that were just they they were like terrible. You know, the worst was the guy in the Chakuzi drinking champagne, which just it was so negatively viewed.
所以，几年前，也就是在新冠疫情爆发很久之前，关于硅谷某家公司的一则新闻传开了。听听NBC《今日秀》的这段剪辑。不满的员工泄露了一份人力资源部门的内部备忘录，禁止远程办公，称一些最好的决策和见解来自走廊和自助餐厅的讨论、结识新朋友以及即兴的团队会议。当我们居家办公时，速度和质量往往会受到牺牲。走廊和自助餐厅的讨论、结识新朋友以及即兴的团队会议。当我们居家办公时，速度和质量往往会受到牺牲。所以尼克，告诉我为什么雅虎首席执行官玛丽莎·梅耶尔想要取消公司允许员工居家办公的政策。
So, some years ago, and this is long before the COVID pandemic hit us, a new story broke about a certain company in Silicon Valley. Listen to this clip from NBC's Today Show. Discrentled employees leaked an internal memo from human resources that bands telecommuting, saying, some of the best decisions and insights come from hallway and cafeteria discussions, meeting new people and in prompt to team meetings. Speed and quality are often sacrificed when we work from home. away and cafeteria discussions, meeting new people and in prom to team meetings. Speed and quality are often sacrificed when we work from home. So Nick tell me why Yahoo CEO Marissa Mayor wanted to cancel the company's policy to allow
当然。她接手时，有人必须扭转公司局面。她在任职不久后说，她发现有一大群人在居家办公。但他们中的许多人整天根本没有登录。对正在发生的事情没有太多的评估。很明显，虽然他们中有些人做得很好，但其他人基本上把它当作一种延长假期的方式。而且你知道，这很有趣，当我与她交谈时，她说，看，居家办公可以很棒，但你需要一个绩效评估系统。你需要确保在家的人确实在工作，而不是在偷懒。她说在那时，我们雅虎没有这样的系统。所以我基本上，你知道，暂时暂停了居家办公计划，直到我们引入了一个绩效系统，然后，
employees to work from home. Sure. She took over in Chousine as the, ah, someone has to turn around the company. And she said not long into her tenure there. She discovered there's a whole group of people that were working from home. But many of them were just not logging in the entire day. There wasn't much assessment what was going on. It was clear, well, while some of them are doing really well, others were basically using it as a way to take an extended holiday. And you know, it's kind of intriguing when I spoke to her, she said, look, working
你知道，稍微放宽了一点。但是的，它在2013年引发了一场媒体风暴。我至今仍记得。是的。所以你已经研究过玛丽莎·梅耶尔在居家办公对生产力影响方面的看法是否正确。但在我们进入科学层面之前，我想花点时间谈谈我们是如何形成这些关于居家办公的态度的历史。
from home can be great, but you need a performance evaluation system. You need to make sure that the people at home are actually working rather than goofing off. And she said at that point, we didn't have an anyahoo. So I basically, you know, temporarily pause the working at home scheme until we got a performance system in and then,
所以在新冠疫情之前很久，不在办公室工作的人被视为例外。但有趣的是，当你回顾历史时，大多数人会觉得在家里以外的任何地方工作都很奇怪。是的，你说得完全对。你知道，现在发生的事情让历史变得如此奇怪。所以如果你回到1750年，就在英国工业革命前夕，
you know, relaxed it back a bit. But yes, it generated a storm of media back in 2013. I still remember now. Yeah. So you've done research into whether Marissa Mayer was right in terms of the effects of working from home on productivity. But before we get to the science, I want to talk a moment about the history of how we got to these
基本上我们都在家里工作。我们在田里干活，或者偶尔是熟练的工匠，但没有人真的在家里以外的地方工作。然后办公室工作或工厂工作真正开始于办公室。所以像英国曼彻斯特这样的地方开始有了工业机械。当然，要做到这一点，你需要大型建筑。而且你知道，人们需要开始通勤。但我应该指出，那时，你知道，在1800年，当你谈论通勤时，你是步行去工厂，那真的没那么远。
attitudes about working from home. So long before COVID, people who didn't work in an office were seen as the exception. But what's interesting is that when you look down history, most people would have found it odd to work anywhere other than their homes. Yeah, you're exactly right. You know, what's happened now is made, you know, history so odd. So if you go back to, you know, 1750, just on the eve of the Industrial Revolution in the UK,
大型办公室始于1900年左右，当时大公司有越来越多的文书工作，他们只是有巨大的大厅，里面坐满了职员，他们会进来处理成堆的文件，而且，奇怪的是，尽管在接下来的120年里，直到今年1月，技术发生了彻底的改变，我们仍然非常专注于以一种朝九晚五的时间表来到办公室。而且有趣的是，在此过程中，文化规范和心理规范随着这些工作安排而演变，以至于居家办公的人被视为野心较小、就业能力较差、才华可能较少，其他人甚至因为居家办公而几乎被降级。是的，完全正确。
basically we all worked at home. We worked in the fields or occasionally a skilled craftsman, but no one is really working anywhere else than home. And then office work or factory work really started off with offices. So places like Manchester and the UK started to have industrial machinery. And of course, to do that, you needed scale buildings. And you know, people needed to start to commute. But I should point out back then you know in 1800 when you talk about commuting you're walking to the factory that was really not that far away.
这是其中之一。经济学家可能会称之为“一般均衡效应”，这意味着即使一家公司发现居家办公很棒，他们也很难独自改变它，因为存在负面污名。没有员工希望在简历上写着他们居家办公多年，因为其他公司认为这很糟糕。
The major offices started around 1900 when big companies had you know growing amounts of paperwork and they just have vast halls full of clerks that would come in and process piles of paper and you know, oddly enough, despite the complete change in technology over the next, you know, 120 years up until, you know, January of this year, we were still very much focused on coming into the office on a kind of nine to five schedule. And isn't it interesting that along the way, the cultural norms and psychological norms sort of evolved with these workplace arrangement so that people who work from home came to be seen as less ambitious or less employable, less talented maybe, and others became almost declassied to be working from home. Yeah, exactly.
所以是的，完全正确。需要明确的是，居家办公所需的四样东西是互联网、宽带、笔记本电脑和视频通话。它们从2000年代中期就一直存在。所以最后一个出现的是视频通话，那真的是Skype的黎明。所以Skype在2003年出现。是我。我在加州。到2005-6年它已经成为主流。你好。所以实际上可能已经有15年了，我们本可以有效地居家办公，但直到现在，是整个社会规范阻碍了我们。
It's one of those things. Economists might call it a generally clubrim effect, which means even if one firm figured out working from home was great, it was hard for them to change it alone because there's a negative stigma. No employee wants to have it maybe on their CV that they worked at home for years because other firms think it is bad.
你好吗？谈论我自己太典型了，对不起。系统中存在巨大的惯性，因为，你知道，我们围绕着这样一个理念建立了整个城市：将有一个城市核心区供人们工作，郊区供人们居住。我们建造了高速公路和公共交通系统，将人们从住宅区运送到商业区。几乎就像一旦那种将工作场所与家庭分开的初始模式在人们心中固定下来，围绕它建立起来的惯性就变得基本上不可阻挡了。
And so yeah, exactly right. Just to be clear, the four things we need for working from home are internet, broadband, laptops and video calls. and all of them have been around since the mid 2000. So the last one to come out was video calls and that was really the dawn of Skype. So Skype comes out in 2003. It's me. I'm in Cal. It's kind of main streamed by 2005-6. Hello. So really for probably 15 years now, we could have effectively worked from home, but it was the whole social norms that up until now have held us back.
是的，完全正确。我的意思是，我认为新冠疫情后的一大变化，将由居家办公和另一个问题——社交距离——共同推动。所以我认为未来，很多房地产可能会被改造成公寓，而且，你知道，它的价格会大幅下降，并将吸引改造成公寓。所以我们将有更多混合的生活模式，摩天大楼不全是办公室，我们也不都住在郊区。相反，更多的人住在市中心，租金更低，通勤也更少，因为这是我们塑造它的唯一方式。当然，包括在那种更少的通勤中，
How are you? It's so typical of me to talk about myself, I'm sorry. And this is enormous inertia in the system because, you know, we've built entire cities around the idea that there's going to be this urban core where people work and suburbs where people live. We built highways and public transit systems to ferry people from residential neighborhoods to commercial neighborhoods. It's almost as if once that initial model separating the workplace from the home got fixed in people's minds, there was an inertia that got built up around it that became essentially
将会有更多的居家办公。当我们回来时，尼克·布鲁姆将告诉我们他在一家中国旅行社进行的不同寻常的实验，那里一半的员工留在办公室，另一半被允许居家办公。我们做了很多采访，他们只是说这真的很令人沮丧。或者他们成为了居家办公的三大敌人之一的受害者：床、冰箱或电视。你正在收听《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。尼克·布鲁姆是斯坦福大学的研究员。多年来，他研究了居家办公的现象，并提出了一个看似简单的问题。当人们居家办公时，他们的生产力是更高还是更低？
unstoppable. Yes, exactly. I mean, I think one big change post-COVID, there's gonna be driven both by working from home and also the other issue is social distancing. So I think in future, a lot of that real estate is probably gonna be converted into apartments and it's gonna be, you know, the price of it's gonna drop a lot
当人们居家办公时，他们的生产力是更高还是更低？尼克，你2010年在斯坦福大学教书，班里有一个来自中国的学生，你和他聊了起来。他告诉了你他的公司在中国遇到的一个问题。是什么问题？你知道，作为背景，你知道，情况相当奇怪。我当时在斯坦福大学教授研究生经济学课程。班里大约有15到20名学生。其中一个我很快就发现了。也许，你知道，课程进行到三分之一时，通过交谈，我知道他是詹姆斯·梁，这家大型中国旅行社的首席执行官和联合创始人。他说他们发展得非常快，做得很好，但他们总部在上海。他们的挑战是上海的办公空间极其昂贵。所以他们想弄清楚如何在不投入巨额资金用于不断扩大的昂贵办公室的情况下实现增长。所以他们正在考虑一个居家办公计划。所以你决定与这家名为携程的中国公司合作，找出居家办公在生产力方面是好是坏。
and it's gonna attract conversion into apartments. So we're gonna have much more mixed living modes whereby those skyscrapers aren't all offices and we don't all live out in the suburbs. Instead, there's more people living in their center on lower rents and there's less commuting because it's the only way we're going to be able to shape it. And of course, included in that less commuting
你做的不仅仅是进行一项调查。你决定进行一项实验。是的，你知道，最棒的是，因为詹姆斯是经济学博士生，他对所谓的“随机对照试验”持开放态度。所以非常正式地，他们在携程选择了两个部门：酒店和机票。大约有1000人，他们问谁想居家办公。你知道，令人惊讶的是，或者说不是很有趣，也许没那么令人惊讶，只有一半人自愿参加。所以需要明确的是。你知道，很多人不想居家办公。
will be more working from home. When we come back, Nick Bloom tells us about his unusual experiment at a Chinese travel agency where half of the workers stayed in the office and half were allowed to work from home. We did a lot of interviews and I just said it's really depressing. Or they fell victim to one of the three great enemies of working from home, the bad, the fridge or the television. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Nick Bloom is a researcher at Stanford University. For years, he has studied the phenomenon of working from home and asked a deceptively
所以志愿者往往年龄稍大，更有可能有孩子，住得更远。但随后他们选取了这500名志愿者并进行了正式的随机化。所以詹姆斯在携程电视上从瓮中抽出了一个乒乓球，上面写着“偶数”，这意味着生日是偶数的人，比如你出生在每月的2号、4号、6号、8号、10号等。你就在实验样本中，所以你实际上可以在接下来的九个月里每周居家办公四天。如果你像我一样是奇数，我是5号出生的，你就是对照组，在接下来的九个月里你留在办公室。关于实验还有几点说明。对于每周居家办公四天的员工，他们都在第五天来到办公室。那是他们进行最适合面对面完成的事情的时候，比如团队会议和培训。经理们总是待在办公室。
simple question. Are people more productive or less productive when they working from home and asked a deceptively simple question. Are people more productive or less productive when they work from home? Nick you were teaching a class at Stanford in 2010 and you had a student in the class from China and you got a chatting with him. He told you about a problem his company was having back in China. What was the problem? You know as backstop you know the situation was pretty weird. I was, uh, teaching a PhD at graduate economics class in Stanford. And I have about, you know, 15 to 20 students in the class. One of them I figured out relatively soon. Maybe, you know,
携程的主要担忧是所有公司似乎都有的恐惧，即远程员工会分心，生产力不高。但携程有一个应对计划。如果他们的生产力下降，他们认为这些会被租金的巨大节省所抵消。事实上，这个计算是他们同意进行实验的原因之一。看看他们在租金上节省了多少美元，对比他们可能在生产力上损失了多少美元。然后结果出来了。
a third of the way into the course was James Lee Ang from talking to him who was the, uh, CEO and co-founder of this huge Chinese travel agent. And he said that they were growing really fast doing very well, but they were based at in Shanghai. And their challenge was office space in Shanghai was incredibly expensive. And so they wanted to figure out how to grow without sinking vast amounts of money into ever increasing size of expensive offices. And so they were thinking about a working from home program. So you decided to work with this Chinese company called C-Trip to find out whether working from home was good or bad in terms of productivity.
所以，你知道，结果老实说令人惊叹，这就是为什么，你知道，拥有九个月的时间是如此宝贵，因为起初你可能会想，这不可能是真的。你看到的是，居家办公的员工比办公室里的人生产力高出13%。需要明确的是，这是一个巨大的提升。这几乎相当于每周多工作一天，仅仅是因为让同样的人和同样的团队做同样的工作，也就是接听电话、处理客户投诉、预订等，现在是在家里工作，而不是在办公室。
And you did more than just simply conduct a survey. You decided to conduct an experiment. Yes, you know, the great thing was because James is a PhD economics student. He was open to what's called doing a randomized control trial. So quite formally, they went to in C-Trip, they got two divisions hotel and airfare. There are about 1000 people in them and they asked them who wants to work from home. You know, amazingly, we're not interestingly, maybe as much as amazing, only a half of them volunteered. So it is to be clear. You know, a lot of people don't want to work from home.
他们是否真的计算出了生产力提高带来的美元数字，不仅是生产力提高带来的，还有租金节省带来的？是的，所以他们估计通过居家办公，每位员工每年节省了大约2000美元。你知道，携程就像，你可以想象，对此非常积极，并在实验结束时宣布将该计划推广到整个公司。所以，现在那些非常讨厌居家办公的员工，他们被允许回来并开始在办公室工作了吗？是的，你知道，一个惊人的发现。同样，完全出乎意料的是，嗯，你知道，有两件事，两个要素。一个是最初他们向1000名员工提供，只有500人想居家办公。所以我们的观点是，老实说，会有更多人接受，但很多人不想居家办公，你知道。一个原因是，你知道，想来办公室的人年轻且单身，正如我们所知，在美国大约三分之一的人在工作场所遇到他们的配偶。在中国也有类似的情况。另一件事是，在九个月的实验结束后，记住实验中的每个人都自愿参加了，赢得居家办公彩票的人中大约有一半实际上改变了主意，决定回到办公室，而对照组中所有自愿参加的人，你知道九个月前，只是输掉了彩票。
So the volunteers tended to be slightly older, more like to have kids live further away. But then they took these 500 volunteers and had a formal randomization. So James, on C-trip TV, drew a ping pong ball out of an earn and it said even, so that meant people with even birthdays have you're born on the second, fourth, sixth, eighth, tenth, et cetera, the month. You were in treatment sample, so you actually got to work from home
但在这一点上，他们被允许做任何他们想做的事，只有三分之一的人最终真的回家了。所以实际上在人们尝试过每周居家办公四天后，出现了一股巨大的离开潮，这再次非常令人惊讶。你以为员工的部分薪水是基于绩效的。所以既然他们在家里表现出的生产力高出13%，他们的薪水应该上涨了，但即便如此，他们中的大量人，超过一半的人在投票，从某种意义上说，
for four days a week for the next nine months. And if you're odd like me, I'm the fifth of me, you were the control group and you remained in the office for the next nine months. A few other notes about the experiment. For the workers who went home four days a week, they all came into the office on the fifth day. That was when they did things that were best to do in person, like team meetings and trainings. And managers were always in the office.
用脚投票，因为他们主动要求回到办公室，承担所有的通勤成本和麻烦。尼克，这里面难道没有真正的讽刺吗？公司认为人们的生产力会降低，但实际上人们的生产力更高了，而人们认为他们想居家办公，但一旦他们真的这样做了，他们实际上想回到工作岗位。是的，你知道，这回到了我认为我们真正需要的东西，以及员工平均想要的东西，那就是一种混合。所以携程当时只提供每周在家四天。我想，你知道，我最近确实又和携程联系上了。如果你转向一个他们可以每周居家办公一两天或两天的系统，那会更受欢迎。现在出于后勤原因，他们没有提供这一点。但大多数员工，我们在实验中也看到了这一点，我应该说，在前两三个月，他们真的很高兴，对此非常积极。但随着时间的推移，我们只是收到越来越多关于孤独的报告和抱怨。
The main worry for C-Trip was the fear that all companies seemed to have, that the remote employees would get distracted and not be productive. But C-Trip had a plan to deal with that. If they had declines in productivity, they figured that those would be offset by the huge savings in rent. In fact, this calculation was one of the reasons they agreed to run the experiment in the first place. To see how many dollars they saved on rent versus how many dollars they might lose on productivity. And then the results came in.
而且日复一日地待在家里工作，真的很令人沮丧。你是一个人。所以到了九个月结束时，许多人感到相当惊讶，但他们说，我受不了这个。顺便说一句，我们做了很多采访，很多焦点小组采访，他们只是说这真的很令人沮丧。或者他们成为了居家办公的三大敌人之一的受害者：床、冰箱或电视。所以基本上出了点问题。他们说，看，救救我，让我离开这里。我想回到办公室。我的意思是，这相当令人震惊，但我相信很多人可以感同身受。对我来说，我真的很想念我的同事。我喜欢待在家里。我的意思是，我和我的妻子以及四个孩子住在一起，但这有点让人感到孤立。我很乐意回到办公室，至少每周两三天。而这正是我们在携程看到的情况。所以换句话说，你看到的部分原因是，居家办公可能带来的好处是，你知道，无论你派谁回家，肯定在节省办公空间方面有一些优势，但可能最适合居家办公的人是那些真正想居家办公的人。所以从员工的角度来看，一定程度的灵活性可能是生产力等式的一部分。是的，完全正确。我的意思是，我从这个实验以及我最近所做的更多工作中得出的两点主要结论是选择和灵活性的重要性。所以事实证明，在选择上，人们
So, you know, it was, the results were honestly amazing and this is why, you know, it was so valuable to have nine months because an issue you were thinking, this can't be true. What you saw was the working from home employees were 13% more productive than the people in the office. Just to be clear, that is an enormous uplift. That's almost a day extra week, simply
有非常不同的看法，很难知道，你知道，人们的看法是什么。很大程度上取决于他们的家庭环境如何。他们有空间吗，有空余的房间吗？你知道，他们想待在家里吗？公寓好吗？然后在灵活性上，实际上很难说。所以我们在携程，在焦点小组中发现，很多人说，你知道，我们以为自己会很擅长这个，我们以为自己能应付得来，我以为我在心理上很强大，或者我不觉得，你知道，我不喜欢我的许多员工。实际上想回家，但我意识到在三四个月后，也许我确实想念他们。
from having the same people and the same team doing the same job, which is answering telephone calls, dealing with customer complaints, taking bookings, et cetera, now working at home, rather than the office. bookings, etc. Now working at home rather than the office. And did they actually calculate a dollar figure in terms of increased productivity, not just from the increased productivity, but from the savings on rent? Yes, so they estimated they saved around $2,000 per employee per year from working from home. You know, Cedric was like, as you can imagine,
就像那句老话“小别胜新婚”，这似乎是真的。你知道，尽管很难想象，但我相信现在外面有些人甚至在想，也许那个账户组里真的很烦人的托尼，我有点想他了等等。这似乎就是我们在携程和中国所看到的。而且也许香槟和按摩浴缸在四个月后开始变得陈旧了。你在携程实验中关于离职率也有一些有趣的发现。告诉我关于留住员工方面发生了什么，你发现了什么。是的，另一个惊人的发现是，居家办公的人的离职率下降了一半。所以公司收集了很多调查，
was incredibly positive about this, and at the end of the experiment announced they're rolling the scheme out to the entire company. So, now employees who really hated working from home, were they allowed to come back and start working out of the office? Yes, you know, a striking finding. Again, totally unexpected was, well, you know, there are two things, two elements. One is initially they offered to a thousand employees, only 500 wanted to work from home. So our view would have been, honestly, many more people have taken out, but a lot of people
他们在调查中报告说更快乐了。但是，你知道，我有时有点怀疑。我不知道是否，你知道，很难知道公司是在调查对公司的回应，员工对公司的回应。但是，你知道，更重要的事情是用脚投票。所以携程的员工离职率大约是50%。事实证明，这与英国、美国、澳大利亚等许多国家的平均水平几乎相同，50%左右是正常的。所以大多数人在跳槽前会在一份工作中待大约两年。对于居家办公的员工，他们的离职率从50%下降到25%，这对公司来说当然是一个巨大的优势，因为它避免了招聘、培训和让人们上手的大部分痛苦，结果他们却辞职了。所以我很好奇，当人们想到，你知道，居家办公的旧负面刻板印象时，人们是否忘记了居家办公的人很容易分心，他们会被冰箱、电视和床分心。
do not want to work from home, you know. One reason is, you know, the people that want to come to the office are young and single, as we know, in the US about a third of people meet their spouse in the workplace. Something similar is true in China. The other thing is, after the end of the nine-month experiment, remembering everyone in the experiment and volunteered, around half of the people that won the lottery to work from home actually changed their minds and decided to come back in the office and the control group who'd all volunteered You know nine months ago it just lost the lottery
他们实际上忘记了工作场所也是分心的来源。工作场所通常，你知道，有很多事情在发生。有Slack频道告诉你大楼另一层正在分发免费食物，你知道，有人在过生日。工作场所也不是一个高度专注、集中的环境。如果工作场所是一个高度专注、集中的环境。不，完全正确。所以解释一下，居家办公带来的13%的生产力提高中，大约三分之一是居家员工每分钟的生产力更高。这完全是因为家里平均来说实际上干扰更少。而且从采访中，出现了一些搞笑的故事。
But at this point it were allowed to do whatever they want only a third of them actually ended up going home So there was a huge Move away actually after people have tried it out against working from home for out of five days a week Which again was very surprisingly thought you Thought employees are partly paid on performance. So since they're performing 13% more at home, their pay has gone up, but even so large numbers of them, more than half of them were voting in sense,
我最喜欢的是那个女人说，你知道，当我在办公室时，这太让人分心了，我隔壁隔间的女人剪她的脚趾甲，噢，她拿出这个，你知道，这个脚趾甲剪，她在桌子底下剪，她说在桌子底下，她说她以为我没注意到，但我告诉你我注意到了，我注意到了，这很恶心，你知道，有关于世界杯抽奖的故事，休息室里有蛋糕，有些男朋友和女朋友分手了，你知道，你可以想象。所以，你说得完全对，家里会分心，但事实证明，办公室的干扰要严重得多，所以实际上，你每分钟可以更高效地工作，至少
voting with their feet because they asked to actively come back into the office with all the commute costs and hassle that involved. Isn't there a real irony here, Nick, which is that the company thought that people were going to be less productive but in fact people turned out to be more productive and people thought they wanted to work from home but once they actually did they actually wanted to come back to work. Yes you know it comes
在这个实验中是这样。所以我理解在携程的研究中，一些居家办公的人想回来，也许是因为他们觉得自己在与一直待在办公室的同事相比处于劣势。也许同事们与老板有更多的面对面时间。所以从某种意义上说，这个实验并没有消除居家办公不如办公室工作的社会规范，它基本上把它作为一个短期实验呈现出来。是的，我认为居家办公在实验中的一个阴暗面是居家办公人员的晋升率下降。
back to I think what we really need and what employees want on average is a mix. So C-trip at that point was only offering four out of five days a week at home. I think you know I've actually again caught up with C-trip very recently. If you'd moved to a system where they could have worked from home one or two days a week, that would have been far more popular. Now for logistical reasons they didn't offer that. But most employees, and we saw this in the experiment, I should say, for the first two or three months, they were really happy, they're very positive on it. But as time went on, we just got increasing reports and complaints about loneliness.
所以如果你控制绩效，记住在家的人，13%的人生产力更高，他们本应该以更快的速度晋升。结果他们晋升得没那么快。事实上，他们最终的晋升率大约是居家办公者与办公室工作者的一半。所以晋升率有巨大的下降。当我们问他们时，结果发现有几个因素。一个是你在居家办公，你被遗忘了。所以这是一个严重的缺点，你在一个15人的团队中，假设你们中有三个人居家办公，其余人在办公室，你可能会被忽略。另一件事是当你与携程交谈时，很难处理，他们说，
And it's very depressing being at home day in day out, working there. You're on your own. And so by the time it came to the end of nine months, many people were quite surprised, but they said, I can't hack this. We did a lot of interviews, by the way, a lot of focus group interviews, and they just said it's really depressing. Or they fell victim to one of the three great enemies
嗯，看，晋升的一部分是了解你的同事和了解公司文化等，这确实来自于在办公室，在周围吃午饭和喝咖啡。所以你知道，这有点两难。在家时额外生产力的一部分是因为喝咖啡闲聊的时间少了，但事实证明，其中一些闲聊相当有用。当数亿人没有选择居家办公，但全球大流行突然为他们做出了选择时，会发生什么？你正在收听《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
of working from home, the bed, the fridge, or the television. So something basically went wrong. And they said, look, save me, get me out of here. I want to come back to the office. I mean, it's quite astounding, but I'm sure many people can enter those. For me, I'm really missing my colleagues. I like being at home. I mean, I live with my wife and four kids, but it kind of gets isolating. I'd love to go back into the
这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。新冠疫情重塑了世界。数百万人死亡，无数其他人看到他们的生活被打乱。几乎在一夜之间，在许多国家，居家办公不再是例外，不再是福利，而只是新常态。尼克，你多年来一直在宣扬居家办公的优点。我很好奇这一刻感觉如何。你并没有真正推动这一点，然后突然间成千上万的公司和数百万人一夜之间就开始这样做了。
office in at least for two, three days a week. And that's the same thing we saw in Cetra. So in other words, partly what you're seeing is that they might be benefits from working from home that are just, you know, regardless of who you send home, there are some advantages, certainly in terms of saving on office space, but it may be that the people who actually are best suited to working from home are the people who actually want to be working from home. So some amount of flexibility from the point of view of the employees might be part of the productivity equation. Yes, exactly. I mean, the two main things I took out of this and from more recent work I've been doing is the importance of choice and flexibility. So it turns out on choice, people
你感到措手不及吗？你知道，这是一种奇怪的体验。我前几天在做一些事情，查看“居家办公”这个词在美国报纸中的频率。所以我查看了美国前50大报纸，它在2020年1月到4月之间上升了12000%。所以是的，它是，我的意思是，我对此很着迷。我正在经历它。研究你和你所有朋友都在经历的事情是非常奇怪的。我，我所有的朋友和亲戚等，都在经历完全相同的问题。我应该说，在美国目前，只有40%的人在居家办公。所以30%的人没有工作。
have just really different views and it's very hard to know, you know, what people's views are. Depends a lot on what their home's circumstances are like. Do they have space, a spare room? You know, do they want to be at home? Is there a apartment nice? And then on flexibility, it's actually really hard to tell. So in C-Trip, we just discovered in the focus groups, so many people said, you know, we thought we'd be great at this, we thought we could deal with it, I thought I was mentally strong or I didn't feel like, you know, I didn't like many of my employees. It's actually wanted to go home, but I realized after, you know, three or four months, maybe I did miss them.
30%的人在工作场所工作，他们通常是基本服务人员。但对于我们这些居家办公的人来说，在许多方面，你实际上是幸运的少数，能够工作并能够安全地在家中完成。嗯。所以，关于目前这五分之二的员工，这40%居家办公的员工的转变，非常有趣的一点是，变化发生得如此突然且如此广泛，以至于它似乎在一夜之间改变了规范。所以Zoom通话、电子邮件和电话交谈现在是默认设置。它们不再是工作场所的二等公民。
It's like that old saying absence makes the heart grow fonder and it seemed to be true. You know, as hard as it is to imagine, I'm sure there are some people out there now thinking even that really annoying guy Tony in accounts maybe I miss him a bit etc. That seemed to be what we're seeing with with C-trip and China. And also maybe the champagne and the the Jacuzzi starts to get old after four months. You also had some interesting findings from the C-Trip experiment when it came to quitterates. Tell me what happened in terms of retaining employees what you found. Yeah, another striking finding was quitterates fell by half for the people that worked from home. So the firm collects a lot of surveys
是的，完全正确。很有趣。我正在和我的一位住在伦敦的朋友交谈，他为一家美国公司工作，他正试图在南非建立同一家公司的子公司。他说，直到，你知道，现在，他总是使用Zoom，但他总是，你知道，或者其他团队软件。他总是那个局外人，因为
and they reported in the survey so far happier. But, you know, I'm sometimes slightly skeptical. I don't know whether, you know, it's hard to know the firms were surveying a response to its firm, the employees to the firm. But, you know, the much more important thing is the voting with their feet. So C-trip has about a 50%
其他人都在房间里，而他通常是拨入的。他说突然间，他感到与其他人处于同一水平，每个人都在Zoom上。我也有类似的反馈，实际上我正在向美国的一个国家实验室做演讲，那里有人是残疾人。
quik rate for its employees. It turns out that's almost identical to the average in the UK, US Australia, many countries, 50% about normal. So most people stay about two years in a job before moving on. For the working from home employees, their quik rates are from 50% down to 25%, which of course, the company is a huge upside because it avoided a large chunk of the pain of hiring and training and getting people out to speed just for them to then quit. So I'm wondering if one of the things that people forget when they think about you know the old negative stereotypes of working from home that people are easily distracted, they're going to be distracted by the fridge and the TV and the bed.
她说，你知道，从某种意义上说，这对我是一个很好的平衡器，因为我很难进出办公室。但现在，你知道，都在Zoom上，身体在那里真的不重要。所以它产生了一些不同寻常的影响，既有积极的也有消极的。事实上，你知道，我刚刚赢得了最终的尼克·道特。我正在和一位高科技创业者交谈。她在湾区创办了一家高科技公司。她出生在印度，来到这里
That they actually forget the workplace is also a source of distraction. The workplace is often, you know, there are multiple things going on. There are slack channels that tell you about the free food that's being given away on another floor of the building and you know, there's someone's birthday going on. It's not as if the workplace is a highly focused, concentrating environment either. If the workplace is a highly focused, concentrating environment either. No, exactly right. So just to explain, for the 13% higher productivity from working from home, about a third of that was the home-based employees who are more productive per minute. And that's entirely because home is on average actually less distracting. And from the interviews, there are some hilarious stories that come up.
并在这里创办了公司。她说，她注意到在Zoom上谁发言与谁在面对面时发言非常不同。她说，美国人在会议中非常大声。而且存在一些文化和性别差异。当你进行视频通话时，它们非常不同。许多以前不发言的人现在感到有权发言，因为他们发现视频通话不那么令人生畏。非常有趣。我了解到你已经完成了对近2000名美国人的调查。描绘
My favorite was the woman that said you know when i'm in the office it's so distracting the woman in the cubicle next to me clips her toenails oh she takes out this you know this toenail clip us and she clips it under the table and she said under the desk she said she thinks i don't notice but i tell you i notice i notice it's disgusting you know there's that there are stories of world Cup sweepstakes, of there's a cake in the breakout room, some of these boyfriend and girlfriend of left, you know, you can imagine. So, you're exactly right, home is distracting, but the office is, it turns out to be significantly more distracting, and so actually, you can work more efficiently per minute, at least
一下那些报告成功转向居家办公的人和那些不能或不这样做的人的形象。所以你知道一个巨大的因素很明显是教育。所以并不是受过教育让你更擅长居家办公。而是受过教育意味着你处于那种可能可以居家办公的工作类型中。所以如果我们看看居家办公的工作，它们往往是，你处于那种可能可以居家办公的工作类型中。所以，如果我们看看居家办公的工作，它们往往是更偏向管理和专业。你可以想象，那些通常在办公室预先完成的事情。
in this experiment. So I understand with the C-Trep study, some people who were working from home wanted to come back, perhaps because they felt like they were losing out to colleagues who were in the office all the time. Maybe the colleagues were getting more face time with the bosses. So in some ways the experiment didn't do, it didn't do away with the social norm that working from home was inferior, it basically laid it out as a short-term experiment. Yes, the one dark side, I'd say, of working from home from the experiment was the drop in promotion rates for people working from home.
在这个实验中。我理解在携程（C-Trip）的研究中，一些居家办公的人想要回到办公室，可能是因为他们觉得自己在与那些一直待在办公室的同事竞争中处于劣势。也许同事们能有更多与老板面对面交流的机会。所以在某种程度上，这个实验并没有消除“居家办公不如办公室办公”的社会规范，它基本上只是将其作为一个短期实验来呈现。是的，我认为居家办公实验的一个阴暗面是居家办公人员的晋升率下降了。
So if you control for performance, remember the people at home were sick, 13% were productive, they should have been promoted at a much faster rate. And it turns out they're promoted less rapidly. In fact, they're roughly their eventual promotion. It was roughly half for those at home versus at the office. So there's a huge drop in promotions. And when we asked them, it turned out looking into there's a couple of factors. One is you're working from home, you're you're forgotten about. And so that's a serious downside that you're in a team of 15. And let's say there's three of you working from home, the the rest in the office you can be passed over. The other thing that was tricky to how to deal with when you spoke to C-Trip, they said,
如果我们控制绩效变量，请记住居家办公的人并没有生病，他们的生产力提高了13%，他们本应以更快的速度获得晋升。但事实证明，他们的晋升速度反而变慢了。事实上，他们最终的晋升率大约是办公室员工的一半。所以晋升率出现了巨大的下降。当我们询问他们时，发现有几个因素。一是居家办公让你被遗忘了。这是一个严重的弊端，如果你在一个15人的团队中，假设有3个人居家办公，其余人在办公室，你可能会被忽视。另一件在与携程沟通时比较棘手的事情是，他们说，
well look, part of being promoted is knowing your colleagues and knowing about the firm culture etc. and that does come from being in the office and having lunch and coffees around. So you know, it's a bit of a ban. Some of the extra productivities at home is because there's plenty less time chit-chatting over coffee but some of that chit-chat turns out to be pretty useful. What happens when hundreds of millions of people don't make a choice to work from home, but a global pandemic suddenly makes the choice for them. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta.
好吧，晋升的一部分是了解你的同事和公司文化等，而这确实来自于在办公室工作以及一起吃午餐和喝咖啡。所以，这有点像是一种禁令。居家办公带来的额外生产力部分是因为减少了喝咖啡时的闲聊时间，但事实证明，其中一些闲聊是非常有用的。当数亿人不是主动选择居家办公，而是全球大流行病突然替他们做出了选择时，会发生什么？你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. The COVID-19 pandemic has reshaped the world. Millions of people have died and countless others have seen their lives disrupted. Virtually overnight, working from home in many countries became not an exception, not a perk, just the new normal. Nick, you've been preaching the virtues of working from home for years. I'm curious what this moment feels like. You don't really move the needle on that, and then suddenly thousands of companies and millions of people start doing it overnight.
这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。新冠疫情重塑了世界。数百万人失去了生命，无数人的生活被扰乱。几乎在一夜之间，在许多国家，居家办公不再是例外，不再是福利，而成了新常态。尼克，多年来你一直宣扬居家办公的优点。我很好奇你对这一刻有何感受。你并没有真正推动这一进程，然后突然间，成千上万家公司和数百万人一夜之间就开始这样做了。
Have you suffered whiplash? You know, it is a weird experience. I was doing something the other day looking at the frequency of the world working from home in US newspapers. So I looked at the top 50 US newspapers and it went up 12,000% between January and April 2020. So yeah, it's, I mean, I'm fascinated by it. I'm living it. It's very odd to be researching something that you and all your friends are living in. I, all my friends and relatives, etc., are going through exactly the same issue. I should say that in the US currently, only 40% of people are working from home. So 30% of people are not working.
你感到措手不及吗？这确实是一种奇怪的体验。前几天我做了一些研究，查看了美国报纸中“居家办公”一词出现的频率。我查看了美国排名前50的报纸，发现从2020年1月到4月，这个词的出现频率上升了12,000%。所以，是的，我对此非常着迷。我正在经历它。研究你自己和所有朋友都在经历的事情是非常奇怪的。我所有的朋友和亲戚等都在经历同样的问题。我应该说，目前在美国，只有40%的人在居家办公。所以有30%的人没有工作。
And 30% of people are working on business premises, which are typically essential service workers. But for those of us that are working from home, in many ways, you're actually in the lucky minority that we're able to work and able to do this safely at home. Hmm. So, one of the things that's very interesting about the current shift for this two in five workers, this 40% of workers that are working from home, is that the changes happen so suddenly and is so widespread, that it seems to have changed norms overnight. So Zoom calls and emails and phone conversations are now the default. They no longer the second-class citizen in the workplace.
还有30%的人在工作场所办公，他们通常是基本服务人员。但对于我们这些居家办公的人来说，在很多方面，你实际上是幸运的少数派，能够工作并安全地在家中完成这些工作。嗯。所以，关于这五分之二的员工（即40%居家办公的员工）目前所经历的转变，非常有趣的一点是，这种变化发生得如此突然且如此广泛，以至于它似乎在一夜之间改变了规范。所以Zoom通话、电子邮件和电话交谈现在成了默认方式。它们不再是职场中的二等公民了。
Yeah, exactly. It's funny. I was talking to a friend of mine that lives in London and he worked for US company and he's trying to set up a startup of the same company company subsidiary in South Africa. And he was saying, he up until, you know, now he was always on Zoom, but he was always, you know, or whatever teams. He was always the other one out in the sense
是的，没错。很有趣。我和一位住在伦敦的朋友聊天，他在一家美国公司工作，他正试图在南非为同一家公司建立子公司。他说，直到现在，他虽然一直使用Zoom或Teams之类的工具，但他总是那个局外人，因为
that everyone else is in the room and he was typically dialing in. He said suddenly, he felt on the level with everyone else that everyone was on Zoom. And I had a similar feedback, actually I was giving a presentation to one of the national labs in the US and somebody there was disabled.
其他人都在房间里，而他通常是远程拨入。他说突然间，他感到和大家处于同一水平，因为每个人都在Zoom上。我实际上也得到了类似的反馈，当时我正在为美国的一个国家实验室做演讲，那里有人是残疾人。
And we're saying she was saying, you know, in some sense this has been a great level of for me because I struggled to get into the office and back. But now, you know, all on Zoom and being physically there really doesn't matter. So it has had some unusual effects, both positive and negative. And in fact, you know, I just won Final Anicked Out. I was talking to someone that starts a high tech runner. She founded a high tech company out in the Bay Area. She was born in India and came over
她说，在某种意义上，这对她来说是一个很好的平衡器，因为她很难往返办公室。但现在，大家都用Zoom，身体是否在场真的不重要了。所以它产生了一些不同寻常的影响，既有积极的也有消极的。事实上，我刚和一位高科技创业者谈过。她在湾区创办了一家高科技公司。她出生在印度，来到这里
and started the company here. And she was saying, she notices on Zoom who speaks up is quite different from who does it in person. And she was saying, Americans are like, amazingly loud in meetings. And there's some cultural and gender differences. They're quite different when you're on video course. A number of people that previously didn't spoke up have now felt actually empowered to talk because they find it less intimidating on a video course. Very interesting. I understand you've completed a survey of nearly 2,000 Americans. Paint
并在这里创办了公司。她说，她注意到在Zoom上，谁发言的情况与面对面时大不相同。她说，美国人在会议中声音大得惊人。而且存在一些文化和性别差异。当你进行视频通话时，情况完全不同。许多以前不发言的人现在感到有权发言了，因为他们觉得视频通话没那么令人生畏。非常有趣。我了解到你完成了一项针对近2000名美国人的调查。请为我
me a picture of the people who report making a successful switch to working from home and the people who can't or don't. So you know one huge factor is clear education. So it's not that being educated makes you better working from home. It's that being educated means you're in the type of job that means you can probably work from home. So if we look at working from home jobs, they tend to you're in the type of job that means you can probably work from home. So, if we look at working from home jobs, they tend to be much more managerial professional. You can imagine that the kind of things that are typically done beforehand in the office
描绘一下那些成功转向居家办公的人，以及那些不能或没有这样做的人的画像。所以，一个巨大的因素很明确，那就是教育程度。并不是说受过教育让你更擅长居家办公。而是受过教育意味着你从事的工作类型使你很可能可以居家办公。所以如果我们看看居家办公的工作，它们往往是管理类或专业类工作。你可以想象，那些通常在办公室里完成的事情
and so it can be easily shifted home. If you look at people with a high school degree or less, so those that left school, 16, 17, 18, their formal act to be in retail, maybe it's in construction, manufacturing, the types of things you need to be on site. So education has become an enormous divider actually in terms of who can work from home. The other couple of factors that we picked up on, again, kind of links to wealth and education is having functional internet. It's astounding, but only 65% of Americans in our survey report having internet connectivity good enough to run a video call, a high quality video call.
因此它可以很容易地转移到家里。如果你看看那些高中及以下学历的人，也就是那些16、17、18岁就辍学的人，他们的正式工作通常是在零售业，也许是在建筑业、制造业，这些工作需要你必须在现场。所以，教育实际上已经成为谁能在家办公的一个巨大分歧点。我们注意到的另外几个因素，同样与财富和教育有关，那就是拥有功能性的互联网。这令人震惊，但在我们的调查中，只有65%的美国人表示他们拥有足以进行视频通话（高质量视频通话）的互联网连接。
So for those of us that living in nice parts of cities, it seems totally standard. You have good internet, but a lot of poorer urban areas or rural areas, they have internet, but it flakes in and out, and so you can't really have video calls. The other thing is having space at home, so people have been able to make this a success, report having their own room that's not their bedroom so they can work quietly. In the survey data, only 49% of Americans have their own room that's not their bedroom, so most people are working from home in a room, you know, their husband or wife in the same room or kids running around, et cetera.
所以对于我们这些住在城市好地段的人来说，这似乎完全是标准配置。你有很好的互联网，但许多较贫穷的城市地区或农村地区，他们有互联网，但信号时断时续，所以你无法真正进行视频通话。另一件事是家里的空间，所以那些能够成功实现居家办公的人，都报告说他们有自己的房间，而不是卧室，这样他们就可以安静地工作。在调查数据中，只有49%的美国人拥有除卧室以外的独立房间，所以大多数人是在一个房间里居家办公，你知道，丈夫或妻子在同一个房间，或者孩子跑来跑去等等。
So I just want to be, you know, very clear, COVID working from home is not great. Post COVID, I think will be this Navanna where we're doing it, you know, two, one, two, three days a week. Our kids are back in school, we have proper equipment, we have a piece and a quarter of our own room because you know, our husband and wife
所以我只是想非常明确地说明，新冠疫情期间的居家办公并不理想。我认为疫情之后将是一个乌托邦，我们会每周在家办公一、二、三天。我们的孩子回到学校，我们有合适的设备，我们有属于自己的空间，因为你知道，我们的丈夫和妻子
they're out of work and so we can get on with it. So what I hear you saying of course is that there is this massive worldwide experiment that is unfolding before our eyes. There's already some data starting to come in about its effects. I just read a paper by Lingfang Bao and colleagues. They analyze the effects of working from home arrangements as a result of COVID by examining productivity at BIDU, which is one of China's biggest IT companies, and they get mixed results. Some people report higher productivity, others, especially people working in big teams on complex or highly collaborative projects. They report lower productivity.
他们不用工作，所以我们可以继续工作。所以我听到你说的当然是，我们眼前正在展开一场巨大的全球性实验。已经有一些关于其影响的数据开始出现。我刚读了一篇由Lingfang Bao及其同事撰写的论文。他们通过检查中国最大的IT公司之一百度（BIDU）的生产力，分析了新冠疫情导致的居家办公安排的影响，结果喜忧参半。有些人报告生产力提高，而另一些人，特别是那些在大型团队中从事复杂或高度协作项目的人，则报告生产力下降。
Does that surprise you at all? No, I think, you know, the stories we're getting out from talking to firms and from the data is, what I would call day-to-day things, which is kind of continuing activities we've always been doing, which is a bit like, well, the folks I was talking about in C-trip, they're basically making calls and taking bookings.
这让你感到惊讶吗？不，我认为，你知道，我们从与公司交谈和数据中得到的故事，是我所说的日常事务，也就是我们一直在做的持续性活动，这有点像，嗯，我刚才提到的携程（C-trip）的员工，他们基本上是在打电话和处理预订。
That seems to work pretty well. So that, you know, repeating what you've done before, nothing too innovative, nothing too unusual on you, and you know, the peace and quiet at home works quite well. So that, you know, repeating what you've done before, nothing too innovative, nothing too unusual, and you know, the peace and quiet at home works quite well. What appears to be more of a struggle is more creative activities, bigger team group activities. So I'd say that's more long run. It's kind of like what, as economists, you might call intangible investments. And it goes back to quips, you know, guys like Steve Jobs made, you know, oh, they're quote from Mr. May,
这似乎效果很好。所以，你知道，重复你以前做过的事情，没有什么太创新的，没有什么太不寻常的，而且你知道，家里的宁静效果相当好。所以，你知道，重复你以前做过的事情，没有什么太创新的，没有什么太不寻常的，而且你知道，家里的宁静效果相当好。看起来更困难的是更具创造性的活动，更大的团队小组活动。所以我说这更长远。这有点像我们作为经济学家所说的无形投资。这回到了史蒂夫·乔布斯（Steve Jobs）等人所说的俏皮话，你知道，引用梅先生（Mr. May）的话，
you've really got to be in the building and talking to others, you know, kicking back, you know, talking over the water cooler to come out with some of these ideas. So I think in the short run, productivity's actually looking surprisingly good. What I worry about is, you know, innovation and creativity. For example, you know, next year's new iPhone, will that
你真的必须在办公楼里和别人交谈，你知道，放松一下，在饮水机旁聊天，才能想出一些这样的点子。所以我认为在短期内，生产力看起来出奇地好。我担心的是创新和创造力。例如，明年的新iPhone，它会
be that impressive because all the innovation and research is going into it right now. I presume it's much harder to do working from home. Right, and you mentioned Steve Jobs a second ago. This is almost a mantra in Silicon Valley, which is the chance encounters that happen when people work together, they bump into each other in the hallway and in the kitchens. Steve Jobs basically designed Apple to encourage chance encounters.
令人印象深刻吗？因为所有的创新和研究现在都投入其中。我推测居家办公要做到这一点要困难得多。没错，你刚才提到了史蒂夫·乔布斯。这几乎是硅谷的口头禅，即人们一起工作时发生的偶然相遇，他们在走廊和厨房里撞见彼此。史蒂夫·乔布斯基本上设计了苹果公司来鼓励这种偶然的相遇。
So really the question that you're asking is, what happens when you turn off that serendipity? Yeah, what's amazing is there's so much money invested by firms in this, you know, you think of the billions and billions of dollars that high tech firms, but also investment banks or professional service firms have spent on super fancy offices. They're trying to persuade people to come in.
所以你真正问的问题是，当你关掉那种机缘巧合时会发生什么？是的，令人惊奇的是，公司在这方面投入了大量的资金，你知道，想想高科技公司，还有投资银行或专业服务公司在超级豪华办公室上花费的数十亿数十亿美元。他们试图说服人们进来。
So the amazing artworks, the incredible free food, the ping pong table, the, you know, the table football table, the astounding, you know, floor to ceiling glass, the incredible free food, the ping pong table, the table football table, the astounding floor to ceiling glass, the incredible gardens, all of that is to drag people into the office. Hi everyone, my name is Kevin and today we're going inside the multi-million dollar tree house conference room. Now, got a knot in your back, schedule a massage, looking for inspiration, attempt to talk. We have our bike room, our bike room holds 92 bikes. It's all
所以那些令人惊叹的艺术品、令人难以置信的免费食物、乒乓球桌、桌上足球桌、令人震惊的落地玻璃、令人难以置信的免费食物、乒乓球桌、桌上足球桌、令人震惊的落地玻璃、令人难以置信的花园，所有这些都是为了把人们拖进办公室。大家好，我叫凯文，今天我们要走进价值数百万美元的树屋会议室。现在，背部酸痛吗？预约按摩吧。寻找灵感？尝试交谈。我们有自行车室，我们的自行车室可容纳92辆自行车。这一切
about encouraging our employees to reduce their carbon. First of all, you notice that you're getting a view and natural light, which is important. There's research that's shown how natural light in views help people focus and process information in a more effective way. I think it is important, you know, for my own experience, honestly, just of my self-interrespect, a lot of my, you know, best research pieces have come from discussions over lunch and here in conferences.
都是为了鼓励我们的员工减少碳排放。首先，你会注意到你拥有视野和自然光，这很重要。有研究表明，视野中的自然光如何帮助人们以更有效的方式集中注意力和处理信息。我认为这很重要，你知道，就我自己的经验而言，老实说，仅仅从我个人的角度来看，我的许多最好的研究成果都来自午餐时的讨论和这里的会议。
But I think it is really important, but I must say that, you know, the research based on this is not entirely conclusive, and there's certainly fantastic creations that happen by people working alone. You can come up with lots of examples of that too. I'm wondering, the picture you're painting here, if you asked me at the start of 2020, can 40% of the country work from home? I would have probably said no, it would be very hard, probably impossible. And clearly now that's been proven untrue, I think a large number of people
但我认为这确实很重要，但我必须说，基于此的研究并不完全具有结论性，而且人们独自工作时肯定也会产生出色的创造。你也可以举出很多这样的例子。我在想，你在这里描绘的图景，如果你在2020年初问我，全国40%的人能居家办公吗？我可能会说不，那会非常困难，甚至可能是不可能的。显然现在这已被证明是不真实的，我认为大量的人
are making it work. But I think the picture that's emerging from this conversation is how complex the question actually is and how much it's connected to individual people's life situations. I mean, you know, I've gotten to spend more time with family over the last few months as I'm working, which has been wonderful. But I can also imagine that people may perhaps who might not want to spend large amounts of time with family. Maybe they don't have a happy family situation. Maybe they're single and they're living by themselves and it's extremely lonely. And so the idea that there's a one-size-fits-all rule that's going to mean
正在让它发挥作用。但我认为从这次谈话中浮现出的图景是这个问题实际上有多复杂，以及它与个人生活状况的联系有多紧密。我的意思是，你知道，过去几个月我能花更多时间陪伴家人，同时还在工作，这真是太棒了。但我也可以想象，有些人可能不想花大量时间与家人在一起。也许他们没有幸福的家庭状况。也许他们是单身，独自生活，感到非常孤独。所以，认为有一个“一刀切”的规则，意味着
everyone working from home is more productive or everyone working from home is more unhappy, that simply breaks down, doesn't it? Exactly, so again you see this so much in the survey data, so just to give you one figure, we ask people post COVID, how many days would you want to work from home? And 20% of people say none, 20% of people do not want to work from home whatsoever, and they may be many of the types of people you mention, they have very small apartments or they don't have great family situations. Then there's 25% of people that want to work from home five days a week. They never want to go back to the office again.
每个人居家办公都更有效率，或者每个人居家办公都更不快乐，这根本站不住脚，不是吗？没错，所以你再次在调查数据中看到了这一点，仅举一个数字，我们询问人们疫情后，你想在家办公多少天？20%的人说一天也不想，20%的人根本不想居家办公，他们可能是你提到的许多类型的人，他们公寓很小，或者家庭状况不太好。然后有25%的人想每周在家办公五天。他们再也不想回到办公室了。
And then the remaining 55% are a big spread. So this is something, having worked for years, all kinds of different parts of economics research. I can't think of an area I've seen in such differing views. So the average person, if there's such a person, wants to work from home typically two days a week, but that average hides enormous variation.
剩下的55%分布很广。所以这是我在经济学研究的各个不同领域工作多年后，想不出还有哪个领域能看到如此不同的观点。所以普通人，如果存在这样的人的话，通常想每周在家办公两天，但这个平均值掩盖了巨大的差异。
So I think for firms, choices, gonna be absolutely essential to get this right. I think for firms choices, going to be absolutely essential to get this right. You know, I recently came by this part in the news on CNBC about the real estate market in New York City. Take a listen, Nick. The big worry here and the big numbers was this rapid rise in empty apartments, the inventory of rental listings soaring 85% we now have a vacancy rate that is the highest in Manhattan on record. So Nick, beyond what happens to workers and companies, what do you think
所以我认为对于公司来说，选择将是绝对必要的，才能把这件事做好。我认为对于公司来说，选择将是绝对必要的，才能把这件事做好。你知道，我最近在CNBC的新闻中看到了关于纽约市房地产市场的这一部分。听听看，尼克。这里最大的担忧和最大的数字是空置公寓的迅速增加，租赁房源的库存飙升了85%，我们现在的空置率是曼哈顿有记录以来的最高水平。所以尼克，除了对工人和公司发生的事情之外，你认为
the effects of COVID and working from home might be on cities and where we decide to live? So I have to say I think it's you know it's not good for cities. So just to be clear, there's plenty of people saying, well, cities have seen this all before. They always bounce back. There's been plenty of pandemics. That's true. But if you look, for example, they bounce back, well, they take a long time, and in the words of Keynes,
新冠疫情和居家办公对城市以及我们决定居住的地方可能会产生什么影响？所以我必须说，我认为这对城市来说不是好事。所以明确一点，有很多人说，嗯，城市以前都经历过这些。它们总是会反弹。有很多大流行病。这是真的。但如果你看，例如，它们反弹，嗯，它们需要很长时间，用凯恩斯的话说，
John Maynard Keynes in the long-run rule dead. So just as a... What? One anecdote. If you look at London, I was watching something on CNN with somebody saying, you know, what one anecdote, if you look at London, I was watching something on CNN with somebody saying, you know, of course, London recovered after the plague. That's true. But if you look at the data 10 years after the Great Plague, 30% of buildings were still
约翰·梅纳德·凯恩斯（John Maynard Keynes）在长期内我们都死了。所以作为一个……什么？一个轶事。如果你看伦敦，我当时在CNN上看到有人说，你知道，什么一个轶事，如果你看伦敦，我当时在CNN上看到有人说，你知道，当然，伦敦在瘟疫后恢复了。这是真的。但如果你看大瘟疫10年后的数据，30%的建筑物仍然
empty. So, you know, my prediction is prices will drop dramatically. It's not that skyscrapers are apartments remain empty. From the clip they are right now, but I wouldn't be surprised to see prices of say Manhattan, you know, apartment and office buildings falling by 30 to 50 percent. And that's the way you keep them off, keep them off. You know, people... And I'm not sure it's a bad thing because it's re-backed. It would take us back to say 2000, or rebalance a bit the country. Rural areas have been left behind and the center of cities have done incredibly well.
空置。所以，你知道，我的预测是价格将大幅下跌。并不是说摩天大楼或公寓保持空置。从目前的片段来看，它们确实如此，但我不会对曼哈顿公寓和办公楼价格下跌30%到50%感到惊讶。这就是你保持它们的方式，保持它们。你知道，人们……我不确定这是一件坏事，因为它会重新平衡。它会把我们带回2000年左右，或者稍微重新平衡一下这个国家。农村地区被抛在了后面，而城市中心做得非常好。
If we rewind that by 20 years back to 2000, you have just a more balanced national setup without such an affordability crisis in the center of cities. There's still much we don't know about what life will look like in a post-COVID era. Will we go back to the way we used to work in the old days, back when more people commuted to an office, and the definition of a workplace was a physical space that you shared with your colleagues, or will we permanently pivot to an era where remote work is more than norm? I ask Nick to predict which way our work practices would evolve, and by extension, our communities writ large. I'm pretty sure most of this will be permanent.
如果我们把时间倒回20年前到2000年，你会有一个更平衡的国家格局，城市中心不会有如此严重的负担能力危机。关于后疫情时代的生活会是什么样子，我们还有很多不知道的地方。我们会回到过去的工作方式吗？回到更多人通勤到办公室，工作场所的定义是你与同事共享的物理空间，还是我们会永久转向远程工作成为常态的时代？我请尼克预测我们的工作实践将如何演变，进而预测我们的社区将如何演变。我很确定大部分都将是永久性的。
So, you know, I can give you... There are four reasons that are driving permanence. Firstly, this is turned out to be a great experience in the sense that 70% of companies have reported what convoem has turned out better than predicted great experience in the sense that 70% of companies have reported what Convorm has turned out better than predicted, so they're much more enthusiastic. Secondly, the stigma seems to have evaporated, so again in survey data, three quarters of people report. Their perception is a big drop in stigma. Thirdly investment, so we collected data and the average person in America has invested 12 hours and about a thousand
所以，你知道，我可以给你……有四个原因在推动这种永久性。首先，这被证明是一次很棒的经历，因为70%的公司报告说，居家办公的结果比预期的要好，所以他们更加热情。其次，污名似乎已经消失了，所以同样在调查数据中，四分之三的人报告说。他们的看法是污名大幅减少。第三是投资，所以我们收集了数据，美国普通人已经投资了12个小时和大约一千
dollars setting up working from home. So, you know, to take me personally, I spent a while figuring out how all these, you know, zoom and teams and chime and everything works and I bought a proper webcam and a mic and, you know, tried to organize the room a bit. And then finally, social distancing. My prediction is just to put figures on it actually is before COVID, 5% of working days in America, or a full time at home, during COVID, it's about 40% so 40% of our working days are at home, post COVID from talking to firms and from our service, it looks something like 20%. So we're going to, you know, wind back a bit from where we are now because, you know, no one's going to be full time at home, or very few people, but we're well above what
美元来建立居家办公环境。所以，你知道，就我个人而言，我花了一些时间弄清楚所有这些Zoom、Teams、Chime以及其他一切是如何工作的，我买了一个合适的网络摄像头和麦克风，你知道，试着整理了一下房间。最后，社交距离。我的预测是，实际上给它加上数字，在新冠疫情之前，美国5%的工作日是全职在家，在疫情期间，大约是40%，所以我们40%的工作日是在家，疫情后，从与公司交谈和我们的调查来看，看起来大约是20%。所以我们会从现在的位置稍微回撤一点，因为，你知道，没有人会全职在家，或者很少有人会，但我们远高于
we were before COVID. I'm wondering, Nick, if you're hiring an employee, maybe you are less interested is the employee in the same zip code as I am, or in the same city as I am. Maybe now if you're a company, you actually can hire more widely. Maybe you can actually look to rural areas or even other countries for labor in ways that you couldn't earlier. In other words, it actually might unleash a lot of people who previously could not find their way
我们在新冠疫情之前的情况。我在想，尼克，如果你在招聘员工，也许你对员工是否在同一个邮政编码区，或者在同一个城市不太感兴趣。也许现在如果你是一家公司，你实际上可以更广泛地招聘。也许你实际上可以寻找农村地区甚至其他国家的劳动力，这是你以前无法做到的。换句话说，它实际上可能会释放出许多以前无法找到通往
to an expensive Manhattan job interview, now can actually be in the running for that job. No, exactly. I think this is going to be great for rebalance in the economy. So many of what I see the political troubles in the US and also my homeland, the UK are from this increasing, growing rural urban divide. And the rural parts of the country felt left behind, you know, felt forgotten about by urban elites, et cetera. Now, if suddenly we allow both people to move out of cities into the
昂贵的曼哈顿工作面试机会的人，现在实际上可以参与该职位的竞争。不，完全正确。我认为这对重新平衡经济将是伟大的。我在美国以及我的祖国英国看到的许多政治麻烦，都源于这种日益增长的城乡鸿沟。农村地区感到被抛在后面，你知道，感到被城市精英遗忘了等等。现在，如果突然我们允许人们搬出城市进入
countryside, but also jobs to move, so even if nobody moves, if employers can now hire people in rural areas more easily, that's going to rebalance things. And so you can imagine if we're working from home, let's say three days a week and only coming in the office two days a week, you can be recruiting people far out deep into rural areas. So if a Stanford professor like you can work at Stanford but pay rent in let's say Kansas or in, or in Wahaka, Mexico, why would someone like you choose to live in Palo Alto? Well, well, this comes back to, you know, I guess, inertia.
乡村，同时也允许工作岗位转移，所以即使没有人搬家，如果雇主现在能更容易地在农村地区招聘人员，那将重新平衡一切。所以你可以想象，如果我们居家办公，比如说每周三天，只在办公室工作两天，你就可以在遥远的农村地区招聘人员。所以如果像你这样的斯坦福教授可以在斯坦福工作，但支付堪萨斯州或墨西哥瓦哈卡（Wahaka）的租金，为什么像你这样的人会选择住在帕洛阿尔托？嗯，嗯，这回到了，你知道，我想，惯性。
I mean, it's a good question. If, you know, imagine COVID lasts, you know, the pandemic horrifically lasted for five years. A lot of people be asking themselves that question, why am I living in such expensive areas? You know, it works for us living here, my kids are in local schools, and you know, we have friends locally, et cetera.
我的意思是，这是一个好问题。如果，你知道，想象一下新冠疫情持续，你知道，大流行病可怕地持续了五年。很多人会问自己这个问题，为什么我住在这么昂贵的地方？你知道，这对我们住在这里的人来说很有效，我的孩子在当地学校上学，而且，你知道，我们在当地有朋友等等。
But I guess if it's lasted forever, and again, just to be clear, post pandemic, I see us going back into the office two, three days a week. But there are certain jobs, I think, it's become clear that they can just be done entirely remotely. And for those jobs, you may well see a lot of people moved, you might live in Hawaii, might live next to the beach, and then I code for know, code for Facebook.
但我猜如果它永远持续下去，再次明确一点，大流行后，我看到我们每周回到办公室两三天。但有些工作，我认为，已经很清楚它们可以完全远程完成。对于这些工作，你很可能会看到很多人搬家，你可能住在夏威夷，可能住在海滩旁边，然后我为Facebook写代码。
And there's nothing wrong with that. And if that works out, actually, that's great. You may fly to Silicon Valley once every other month to meet in person and spend the rest of your time living out in Hawaii or, you know, living up in the ski slope. So I think we'll see a big increase in that. And in fact, if you look, if you look at the reports from real estate agents, they are talking about there's been an explosion of people wanting to buy what's called lifestyle properties. So, you know, beautiful runches deep at the countryside that, you know, you can buy a small man hat in the apartment or you can buy a 200 acre ranch at and wireming and if you can work remotely, you know, maybe you go for the
这没什么错。如果这行得通，实际上，那太棒了。你可能每隔一个月飞一次硅谷进行面对面会谈，其余时间住在夏威夷，或者，你知道，住在滑雪坡上。所以我认为我们会看到这种情况大幅增加。事实上，如果你看，如果你看房地产经纪人的报告，他们谈论的是，人们想要购买所谓的“生活方式房产”出现了爆炸式增长。所以，你知道，深处乡村的美丽牧场，你知道，你可以买一个小曼哈顿公寓，或者你可以买一个怀俄明州的200英亩牧场，如果你能远程工作，你知道，也许你会选择
lot. But again, you have this divide, don't you, which is that this is speaking now to the people who are the wealthiest people who are able to think that way. And if you don't you, which is that this is speaking now to the people who are the wealthiest people who are able to think that way. And if you don't have the education, the technology, the support from an employer to do this, there's really going to be this bifurcating caste system. Yes, although I think in terms of moving people out to rural areas, you know, it pushes them both directions. You're exactly right. The people who can work from home are educated.
那个。但同样，你面临这种分歧，不是吗？那就是这现在是在对那些最有能力那样思考的富有的人说话。如果你没有教育、技术、雇主的支持来做这件事，真的会形成这种分叉的种姓制度。是的，尽管我认为在将人们转移到农村地区方面，你知道，它将他们推向了两个方向。你是完全正确的。能居家办公的人受过教育。
And so they gain a lot of the direct benefits. It is true though, if a lot of say wealthy New Yorkers move out into the countryside, when they're out there going to demand services, you know, restaurants and go out to gyms, et cetera, and you know, they're not up pay more tax revenue, they're improved local schools. And so that will indirectly spill over to, you know, people that are out there that maybe can't work from home, but will get some of the indirect benefits. So the inequality impacts a bit mixed. I think it will really reduce inequality.
所以他们获得了许多直接的好处。不过确实，如果许多富有的纽约人搬到乡村，当他们在那里时，他们会要求服务，你知道，餐馆，去健身房等等，而且，你知道，他们会支付更多的税收，他们会改善当地学校。所以这将间接溢出到，你知道，那些可能无法居家办公但会获得一些间接好处的人身上。所以不平等的影响有点复杂。我认为它真的会减少不平等。
If we can rebalance things a bit away from cities, it's not like, you know, I was born in London. I lived in London until I was 30. I'm basically a city person, but it's also clear that even for me, one of the reasons I left London and came out to the US is it was just too expensive to live in. And I think it will be better for society if cities were, you know, not so unbelievably expensive. So you could have a more mixed set of people lived in them. And there's more, you know, basically diversity across the US, rather than becoming so geographically segregated by income, which is what's been happening until recently. What's been your most embarrassing work from home moment these last few months?
如果我们能稍微从城市重新平衡一下，并不是说，你知道，我出生在伦敦。我住在伦敦直到30岁。我基本上是一个城市人，但也很清楚，即使对我来说，我离开伦敦来到美国的原因之一就是它太贵了。我认为如果城市，你知道，没有那么贵得令人难以置信，对社会会更好。这样你就可以有更多样化的人居住在其中。而且，你知道，美国各地基本上有更多的多样性，而不是变得如此按收入进行地理隔离，这正是直到最近一直在发生的事情。这几个月你最尴尬的居家办公时刻是什么？
Oh, my most embarrassing work. I mean, I tell you one, this is the classic early days of Zoom. I was on a video call, it was a Zoom call, and I screen shared with some couple of co-authors, and I've forgotten to turn off screen sharing, and at some point one of them is talking, and as you do was losing you know concentration and went to start doing some emails and was typing or reply and my co-author suddenly said hey Nick you do
哦，我最尴尬的工作。我的意思是，我告诉你一个，这是Zoom早期的经典案例。我在进行视频通话，那是Zoom通话，我和几个合著者共享了屏幕，我忘了关闭屏幕共享，在某个时候其中一个人在说话，正如你所做的那样，我失去了注意力，开始处理一些电子邮件，正在打字回复，我的合著者突然说嘿尼克你
realize you're still on screen share and you know he'd very politely taken a while thinking I might turn back but you know for the last five six minutes you must be maybe even ten minutes watching me type emails, clearly paying no attention. One of the things you have to realize when you are working for my home is the office norms just don't apply so it's completely reasonable if you're working for your home to have a cat walk across your camera or a baby crying in the background and one of my colleagues has just had a baby and you know that baby was often sitting in his lap during conference calls and he is cute and it is the way it is in the office it would seem weird but I like the fact that working
意识到你还在屏幕共享吗？你知道他非常有礼貌地花了一段时间，以为我可能会转回来，但你知道，在过去的五六分钟，甚至可能是十分钟，他一直在看我打电子邮件，显然根本没在注意。当你居家办公时，你必须意识到办公室规范根本不适用，所以如果你在家里工作，猫走过你的摄像头或婴儿在背景中哭泣是完全合理的，我的一位同事刚生了孩子，你知道那个孩子经常在电话会议期间坐在他的腿上，他很可爱，事实就是这样，在办公室里这看起来会很奇怪，但我喜欢居家办公的事实是，关于什么是合理的，有一套新的规则。经济学家尼克·布鲁姆（Nick Bloom）在斯坦福大学任教，或者更准确地说，他在他的备用卧室里任教，有时当他的孩子们在练习风笛时，他在浴室里任教。尼克·布鲁姆，感谢你今天加入Hidden Brain。谢谢，这太棒了，谢谢你的邀请。担心的是他们想有一个库尔德语，对不起，我的孩子们在这里，现场直播，寒冷的空气今晚继续在整个地区，一些地方有
from home there's a new set of rules around what's reasonable. Economist Nick Bloom teaches at Stanford or to be more precise he teaches from his spare bedroom and sometimes from his bathroom when his kids are practicing the backbipes. Nick Blue, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thanks, it's been fantastic, thank you for having me. The concern is that they want to have a Kurdish excuse me my kids are here live television on cold air continues across the area tonight potential for some
霜冻和冰冻，一些地方变暖，这需要枫树，大卫·卡梅伦（David Cameron）在谈论，哦，我真的很抱歉，那是我的儿子到了，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，是的，你可以和他喝茶，我真的很抱歉，但是的，好的，好吧，那我们离开，好的，欢迎回来，我周一会回到演播室，所以我以为我会带我的女儿莉娜（Lina）一起来，没
frost and freeze for some of us warm up it's gonna take Maple David Cameron was talking about oh I'm really sorry that's my son arriving sorry Sorry Sorry Yes you can have tea with him I'm really sorry but yeah okay well that's we'll leave All right welcome back I'm gonna be back in studio on Monday so I thought I'd bring my daughter Lina with us It's no
嘿，你能说今天会是晴天吗？不，今天会是晴天。不，今天会很热。好的，干得好。未来7到10天会有很多80多度到90多度的气温。这没有按计划进行，杰基（Jackie）。我们最近回访了尼克·布鲁姆，以了解他对自我们首次播出这一集以来居家办公如何演变的看法。你可能预料到，随着新冠疫情在美国得到更好的控制，更多的员工会回到办公室。
Hey can you say it's gonna be sunny today? No it's gonna be sunny today. No, it's gonna be hot. Okay, good work. Lots of upper 80s and low 90s over the next 7 to 10 days. This didn't go as planned, Jackie. We recently checked back in with Nick Bloom to get his perspective on how working from home is evolved in the year since we first ran this episode. You might expect that with the COVID-19 pandemic more under control in the US, more employees will be returning to the office.
但一些初步数据表明，居家办公依然普遍。根据盖洛普（Gallup）的数据，2021年秋季，45%的美国员工至少兼职在家工作。尼克·布鲁姆说，这有一个主要原因。目前，美国劳动力市场火爆。由于大流行，许多工人决定辞职或改变职业道路。因此，组织意识到，如果他们想招聘新员工，甚至留住现有员工，他们应该提供每周至少两天的居家办公。一些公司正在选择混合模式，比如周一和周五在家办公，而另一些公司则提供每年一个月的“随处办公”。
But some preliminary data suggests working from home is just as prevalent. According to Gallup, 45% of US employees worked at least part-time at home in the fall of 2021. Nick Bloom says there's one major reason for this. Right now, there's a hot labor market in the US. Because of the pandemic, many workers decided to quit their jobs or change career paths. So organizations are realizing that if they want to hire new employees and even keep the ones they have, they should offer at least two days per week of working from home. Some companies are choosing a hybrid model, like working from home on Mondays and Fridays, while others are offering one full month per year of walking from anywhere.
换句话说，尼克预测，居家办公似乎将持续下去。Hidden Brain由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括Bridget McCarthy、Laura Quarell、Ryan Katz、Kristen Wong、Autumn Barnes和Andrew Chadwick。Tara Boyle是我们的执行制片人。我是Hidden Brain的执行编辑。我们今天的无名英雄是让Hidden Brain团队能够成功居家办公的人。他的名字叫Yatbaraq Adafene，他是华盛顿特区苹果公司的商业专家。当我们的节目在2020年转为独立制作时，我们需要新的电脑。
In other words, Nick predicts, walking from home seems to be here to stay. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Laura Quarell, Ryan Katz, Kristen Wong, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero today is someone who has made it possible for the Hidden Brain team to work from home successfully. His name is Yatbaraq Adafene, and he's a business expert with Apple in Washington, DC. When our show moved to independent production in 2020, we needed new computers.
正如他所知，Yat耐心地引导我完成了为我们新公司开设商业账户的过程，并确保我们在紧迫的时间内拿到了电脑。他自己也是个音响发烧友，这很有帮助。谢谢，是的。欲了解更多Hidden Brain信息，请务必订阅我们的每周通讯。发烧友。我是Shankar Vedantam。很快再见。你这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
Yet, as he's known, patiently walked me through the process of setting up a business account for our new company and ensured we got our computers on a tight turnaround. It helped that he's something of an audio file himself. Thank you, yeah. For more Hidden Brain, be sure to subscribe to our weekly newsletter. file himself. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
然而，正如他所知，他耐心地引导我完成了为我们新公司开设商业账户的过程，并确保我们能快速拿到电脑。他本人也是个音响发烧友，这很有帮助。谢谢，是的。想了解更多《隐藏的大脑》，请务必订阅我们的每周通讯。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。目前该剧集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。